une fois n'est pas coutume cette semaine
les américains avaient les yeux rivés
vers l'europe
mais je ne parle pas vraiment des
matches de football de l'euro vous le
savez on n'est pas très soccer ici
mais le match que tout le monde
attendait se dérouler sur un autre
terrain le terrain diplomatique
mais inutile de vous préciser que la
plupart des médias américains avaient
déjà choisi leur favori nous annonçons
un duel entre les deux hommes comme s'il
s'agissait d'un match de tennis ou même
d'un combat de boxe il était près à
compter les points
le président d'aena mais c'est d'être
non seulement la voix la plus forte
contre l'autoritarisme dans le monde
mais également la meilleur exemple de la
réserve pour laquelle on les connaît
autoritaristes et défaillances
il ne s'agit pas de conclure des accords
mais de fixer les limites avec la russie
selon des données ses conseillers
l'objectif est de regarder poutine droit
dans les yeux
mais à force de nous présenter
l'événement comme un duel entre deux
hommes certains médias américains
semblent avoir oublié l'essence même de
cette rencontre aplanir les angles
relancer des relations au plus bas
depuis bien longtemps il y avait des
dossiers très sérieux abordé pour les
deux présidents et la diplomatie n'étant
pas un ring la réalité souvent bien
moins théâtral les cocos dublinois nièce
plutôt l'équateur nous n'avons ressenti
aucune pression
la conversation est en direct
transparente sans aucun écart
diplomatique par rapport aux sujets
fixée je le répète encore une fois il
n'y a eu aucune pression ni de leur côté
ni d'une autre cela n'aura eu aucun sens
ce n'est pas pour cela que les gens se
réunissent et quant à la première partie
de votre question
le score a le score je crois qu'avant
notre réunion le président maiden a dit
que ce n'était pas des compétitions
sportives
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec lui à
cet égard
sommes nous ici pour compter un score en
général la réunion a été fructueuse
c'était une réunion de fonds en crète
elle s'est déroulée dans une
faire favorable à l'obtention de
résultats dont le principal et les
éclairs de confiance que nous avons
évoqué avec votre collègue d'euronews un
catwalk richesse globale et laisse ses
collègues et suivre les news
malgré tout beaucoup d'éditorialistes
ici on absolument chercher à définir qui
était le vainqueur de cette rencontre
alors pour certains c'est plutôt joe
biden qui aa gagné il s'appuie pour cela
sur la posture la gestuelle le body
language comme on dit ici du nouveau
président des états unis qui aurait tenu
tête aux féroces vladimir poutine et
puis pour d'autres certainement un peu
déçu de l'absence de controverse lors de
ce sommet c'est plus tôt vladimir
poutine qui ressort grandie de cette
rencontre il reproche en réalité un
manque de fermeté de la part de joe
biden des critiques reprises en choeur
par la plupart des élus républicains le
président bailly donne aurait dû
utiliser le sommet d'hier pour montrer
que les etats-unis tiendront la russie
responsable pour sa longue liste de
transgression à la place il a donné un
laissez-passer à vladimir poutine
nous avons besoin d'un réel leadership
qui met le peuple américain à nouveau en
premier de son côté joe biden est rentré
à washington avec le sentiment du devoir
accompli
en poursuivant la rhétorique qui a été
la sienne pendant tout le long de son
périple en europe à savoir l'amérique
est de retour les alliances entre les
etats-unis et les pays occidentaux n'ont
jamais été aussi fortes et on le sait la
politique internationale ne passionne
pas vraiment les foules ici aux etats
unis
un peu à l'image du sport les américains
s'intéressent davantage à ce qu'il se
passe à l'intérieur de leurs frontières
et de ce point de vue là aussi il n'y
aura à des dossiers très compliqué pour
le nouveau président des états unis